okay let's stick with the phones we will
go next to our caller why don't we go to
the seven one eight no caller caller
from seven one eight what's your name
where are you calling from and what's on
your mind today
hey my name is Kareem I'm calling from
New York City I just had two quick
questions one is about the YouTube and
the way there have been be monetizing a
lot of people because I've noticed a lot
of conservative youtubers I've been
trying to turn this into it being
YouTube being anti conservative and I've
noticed a lot of liberal news sites I've
been going through the same thing but
like Lawrence Auburn's go on and it
makes the making it seem like
conservatism
under attack by Google and like the
liberal media whatever when I think it's
pretty much a lot of people even sports
people yeah probably it is YouTube okay
so yeah I just I just wanted to make
sure it was like not just a little I'll
say a little bit more about that cream I
mean yeah if you go on YouTube you will
find left-wing youtubers and right-wing
youtubers who are having the
monetization problems I have seen
right-wing youtubers trying to make the
case that conservatism is being
financially punished by YouTube
we are not conservative and we have been
absolutely crushed by the YouTube ad
boycott and that's why we've been doing
the patreon thing and membership and
coming up with all this new stuff that
we're gonna be rolling out over the next
four to six weeks so I've seen no
evidence whatsoever that it's where you
are on the political spectrum that is
impacting D monetization and as you said
there have been gaming channels
demonetized
sports channels demonetized
it's been a problem and I think what it
is is if you're a right-wing youtuber
you probably pay attention more to other
right-wing youtubers so because of your
echo chamber it sort of seems like it's
mostly right-wingers that are being
affected but it's not the case okay
and my second one is do you think that
maybe the Democrats are putting too much
eggs in one basket leftist Russia Trump
and Pietschmann thing and - would it be
better just to keep them going
I feel like if Trump does get impeached
we get pence and I think pens would be a
much more efficient yeah Republican
president were all of a sudden where
Trump gets kind of gets in the way of
the Republican agenda right pence or
just kind of be like squirt and oil in a
machine all the sudden things start
getting going yep so I let I'm not gonna
deal with the pence part now because
I've talked about it a bunch of times
and I agree with you a hundred percent
so there's there's no nothing to really
discuss there and we had a question
about that earlier are Democrats putting
too much time or energy into the Russia
thing I was worried that they were
before our vacation but I'm really not I
mean you you're not hearing right now
and maybe it's been because of the
hurricane coverage Pat but Democrats
have kind of been laying lower on it on
the Russia stuff and just allowing the
investigation to go I I don't think
Democrats are going too crazy with
Russia right now well I think this whole
Russia story has been happening in waves
every few weeks there'll be a new
revelation and in the response to that I
think Democrats will speak about it for
a good amount of time and then it takes
a little while until the next revelation
comes out and they're able to focus a
little bit more on policy right now it's
a lot about hurricane Harvey so you know
there's been fluctuations I think yeah
so I agree with you Kareem in if the
underlying
I don't think Democrats should go overly
crazy with the Russia stuff because if
the Russia stuff implodes and it pulls
Trump out of office now you've got a run
in 2018 and 2020 on a platform not
against Trump so you need something
other than Russia if the Russia stuff
evaporates and there's nothing there
you also can't run on Russia in 2018 and
2020 so either way Democrats need
something else and I I think that I've
been talking about that quite a bit
thanks Kareem appreciate the call all
right thank you
excellent